Good morning Hank it's Tuesday. Hi
everyone else. I'm Rosie Anna. I'm John's
assistant. I'm also John and Hank's secret
london sister, as of way back when. So
Hank when people find out that I'm John's
assistant, especially because I live so
far away in London, the number one
question they ask is, "so what is it that
you do?" Today I'm going to endeavour to
answer this question, but first I want to
give a little bit of an office tour,
because we've seen your office in
Missoula, Hank, we've also seen Johns
office in Indianapolis. That's a really
hard phrase to say. Office in
Indianapolis. So without further ado, this
is my office. This is my view. These are
the wild animals I can see from my
office. This is the foliage I can see
from my office, and these are the trees.
So for the job itself, a large part of my role is
scheduling, which is lucky, because i am
awesome at it, through the combined
wonder of: Craigslist, shared calendars on
gmail and skype credit, i'm able to
coordinate someone, to come in and
organise John's 'pizza John shirts' by
hues. Very important that they're in
rainbow order. "God I love rainbows." I also
get someone to come in and sit in John's
car seat, to warm it up, um, for about 15
minutes every time before he wants to
take the car out. I would say I spend
about half my time here in the london
office, and I can meet about three days a
week to indianapolis. Hardest part about
this is, probably the, I don't know, say
eight hours, or so, that I'm over the
Atlantic ocean without any internet. This is
particularly difficult for doing my job,
especially because John often calls me
quite casually, throughout the day, to do
things like look up words in the
dictionary for him. Not necessarily for
his next book, just to complete the
crossword. He says it's not cheating if
he asks me. On the upside, my air miles
are awesome, and the crew at Virgin
Atlantic, really know how to make an
amazing gin and tonic. Another key part
of my role is security testing. I feel
like I'm kind of a pro at this, because
I've seen every episode of Homeland at
least six times. I also remember
everything that Nancy McNally - well that
just fell down - has ever said. Okay well
now that's - yeah well done Rosie Anna. So
just like the NSA, I do spend a lot of my
time hacking into John's personal
accounts online. Just to double check all
the security levels, and then I also
change all the passwords, every like,
three hours. When John takes us to DFTBA
con four, I changed that to change the
passwords to every 15 minutes, just to be
super safe. But otherwise my assistantship
is pretty normal. Standard stuff the role
like, washing and blow-drying John's used
tissues, um, so that he can reuse them in
the name of sustainability. And also
ghost writing fan mail from John, to
Steven Gerrard, and by fan mail, I mean
love letters. Out of all my roles. this is
the hardest for me, because I'm a die-hard
West Ham United fan. I have been known to
slip a few references to bubbles, into
these love letters. I will admit that
Stephen Gerrard is a very talented player,
for Liverpool Football Club, and even a
little bit handsome. But I do always
feel like I'm betraying my beloved irons.
But I suppose they gave us Carol so
there you go. Some of the recent projects
I've undertaken in my spare time, include:
building up Henry and Alice's library for
the next 15 to 18 years. Taking them from
the Jolly Postman, right up to the
unbearable lightness of being. Another
thing I'm doing is overseeing the
construction of an exact replica of the
Globe Theatre, in John's back garden,
mainly so his kids could see Shakespeare
as everyone was supposed to see
Shakespeare, standing up. Other priorities
include: building up John's Lauren Conrad
gift collection, with a smidge of
Benedict Cumberbatch and the adolescent
wolf program, just keep everyone happy.
So okay jokes aside, it is honestly the best
job I've ever had. It's really cool
getting to work with you guys. It's
really been earnest, thinking and looking back
at me in 2006. I used to read John's blog,
his very static blog, and 2007 me who was
addicted to brotherhood 2.0. Because the
tools I use now, without even thinking
about it to do my job, just weren't
really possible then. Skype out and shared
calendars, on start emails, that tell me
that it's time for John to put more air
in his tires. Which he spells with an 'i'
which is weird. So basically what I'm
saying Hank, is that we're living in the
future, and I'm loving it. Thanks for
being awesome everyone, and Hank, I will
see you on Friday, bye.